OK, now here’s a question.
What’s the biggest living organism
on the planet?
A whale? A redwood tree?
Arguably it’s armillaria,
a huge honey fungus
living in a forest in Oregon, USA.
It covers over
nine square kilometres
and is thought to be
at least 2,400 years old.
Oh, and it glows in the dark.
Mind blown?
What if we also told you
that other types of fungi
can absorb oil spills,
control insects’ brains
and that fungi in general
are essential
to all terrestrial life on Earth?
And there’s still so much
we don’t know -
more than 90%
of the fungi in the world
are currently unknown to science.
You could say there’s
mush-room for learning.
Now that we’ve got that terrible pun
out of the way,
we can take a closer look
at some fascinating facts
that will make you a real fun-guy
at parties.
Sorry.
If you think of mushrooms
as vegetables on your pizza,
you’re not alone,
thanks to the Victorian botanists
who classified fungi with plants.
In fact, fungi are neither
plant nor animal.
They are in a kingdom
of their own,
but are genetically
much closer to animals.
The genetic code
of a mushroom
has more in common with ours
than a potato’s.
Maybe don’t mention that
to your vegan friends.
Fungi also have the ability
to control other organisms.
While some species of fungi
break down dead leaves and wood,
like the helpful housemate
who always remembers
to take the bins out,
other fungi are mycorrhizal,
they plug into the
root tissue of plants
and pass precious
nutrients between them.
This process forms a dense
fungal network called a mycelium.
Soil often contains masses
of these mycelial threads
connecting different plants,
like fibre-optic cables.
In woods, the network is known
as the wood-wide web
because plants use it to
communicate with one another.
In a fertile pasture, the fungi
feeding on plants below ground
can be many times heavier than
the cows eating the grass above it.
Some fungi get other species
to do the work for them.
The Leucoagaricus uses chemical
signals to ‘employ’ leaf-cutter ants.
The ants work together
to form a supply chain
that can deliver up to 60,000 leaf
fragments an hour to the fungus.
In return, it produces miniscule
ant-sized mushrooms to feed them.
Other fungi employ
more gruesome methods.
Cordyceps infiltrate
their insect host -
for example ants or beetles -
and control their brains,
forcing them to climb up high,
and then bursting out of their bodies
to scatter their spores to the wind.
Talk about evil genius.
Not content with insect mind-control,
some types of fungi
can trouble humans,
causing irritations
like athlete’s foot,
as well as the more
deadly histoplasmosis.
Ergot, a fungus that grows on wheat
and rye, can literally send you mad -
eating bread made from affected flour
is likely to have contributed to mass
hallucinations in medieval Europe.
And you don’t have
to be a seasoned forager
to know that some species
of fungi are highly toxic.
If I were you, I’d avoid anything
with an intimidating biker-gang name
like Autumn Skullcap
or Destroying Angels.
While fungi can, in some cases,
be extremely dangerous,
they are also
an invaluable resource.
For a start, fungi produce
life-saving medicines
such as penicillin.
Yeast is a fungus,
without which we’d have
no bread, wine, beer or cheese.
Even Quorn is made from a fungus.
Basically, without fungi there would
be no middle-class dinner parties.
Mycelium can be used
to make packaging and clothing.
Fungi have been used
to clean up oil spills,
and an itaconic acid
derived from a fungus
is even used to make Lego!
Fungi are also eco-warriors.
They are absolutely essential
to a healthy soil,
and play a key role in trapping
CO2 fixed by plants into the soil,
preventing its return
to the atmosphere.
Over a thousand billion tonnes
of carbon
are locked in the world’s soils.
That’s more than twice
the amount of carbon
held by all the trees on Earth.
If the activity of soil fungi
were to increase,
they could potentially solve
global warming on their own!
But despite their many uses,
and dangers,
of course fungi aren’t
actually ‘good’ or ‘evil’.
They are an incredibly adaptable
and distinct life-form,
playing a key role in
terrestrial life on the planet.
And for that -
and not just because they
taste great on pizzas -
they should be celebrated.